[Music]
i think i have read
somewhere and i'm paraphrasing here that
you you think everyone or any comedy
writer should sort of do a tour of duty
if possible
at snl for a period of time
i'm sure a lot of more people would like
to than ken
but what were some of the lessons
learned from for lack of a better way to
phrase it
so many
i do believe that by the way i think
that if everyone who worked in hollywood
had to work for one year at snl
in general things would be a lot better
so
from a creative standpoint
the thing that snl teaches you is
to not be precious with your own
material
you generally have about four minutes to
do whatever you're gonna do right like
with rare exceptions
you're talking about four minutes and so
you write a sketch
and it's five minutes and 38 seconds
long
and
you go in with a red pen
and you just make giant x's on your
script like cut this cut this cut this
this didn't work change this and and
after doing that every week
for you know seven years
there's almost no joke or piece of
writing that i could put into a script
that i would think that cannot be cut
like it just trains you to say anything
can be cut and
if it improves what you're doing
then cut it and i think that's a really
hard lesson
for some people to learn especially when
depending on where those people where
people come from what their backgrounds
are
if if you grow up in a system
i mean creatively grow up in a system
that doesn't train you not to be
precious with your own material and then
you achieve any kind of success
you are
almost always way too precious about
your material because you have this
sort of personal belief that you you did
this alone it's you know you know you
figured it out you cracked the code and
how dare anybody tell me to cut this or
cut that or how dare the these
executives think that this is too long
and as a result
you know you can look around right now
uh on your streaming service of choice
and you can find a lot of shows and
movies where you think to yourself that
was about 25 minutes too long like that
i liked it it was good but man why was
that so long and the answer is almost
always like they just didn't get tough
enough on their own material yeah so snl
is just ruthless about that it just
doesn't snl is like a
lauren michaels has many aphorisms that
he likes to
dole out to you and as you sit at his
feet and he he dispenses his wisdom
but one of the things he has been saying
for i think about 50 years is
the show doesn't go on because it's
ready the show goes on because it's 11
30 on saturday night
and that ethos sort of permeates
everything and it reinforces this idea
that like you just you work on it and
work on it and work on it until it's
done and then you're done
but
you know
the level of success you have with any
individual sketches a little bit
up to whether or not
it's it's based on whether or not you
are tough enough on your own material so
that's a great lesson that's a really
really wonderful lesson for a writer of
any kind to learn
another thing it teaches you and by the
way i should note if you meet and work
with anyone who went through the snl
gauntlet of fire
everybody has that same
that same sort of attitude toward their
own material
so
when you're talking about an actor like
andy sandberg so my friend dan goran
created brooklyn nine-nine andy samberg
we got andy samberg to star in it andy
sandberg was a very well-known and
beloved comedian
and was pretty famous on his own right
thanks to his own work
and
yet when we would show him cuts of
brooklyn episodes in the early days he
would go like i'm bad in the scene cut
me out of this cut this cut my joke here
it doesn't work cut this cut this it's a
very rare star of a tv show
who will say cut my material you know
like that's not the typical attitude for
like number one on the call sheets star
of the show guy on the poster usually
those people are like wait i want more i
want more put me in this more put my
face on tv more people who went through
snl
judge comedy and material
based on only like is this good is it
funny does it work is it fast is it
quick is it enjoyable
that's a wonderful trait in a producer
slash actor amy poehler's the same exact
way like the so everybody who goes
through this system has this
sense of like it's not about me it's
about the end product and if the end
product is made better by removing me or
removing scenes i'm in
or lines that i have or jokes that i
have then remove them like because
that's the we we all win if this thing
is better
so
there are other ways you can learn those
lessons snl is just a particularly blunt
force trauma way to do it it's a very
like it's a very intense kind of like
like sledgehammer to the head over and
over again that kind of drills this idea
into you
you